We're so excited that you're here.
I can tell you guys have been deprived of humans.
(laugh in the background)
It's just been awesome. When you walked out, we were like
I don't even know what to do,
Heidi you're not wrong. You're absolutely right.
We have been deprived of humans.
However, you're like, it's like being in church
like Saturday night live is my church and
you're a legend and you're just crushing it.
Wasn't it true that you were set in your yearbook?
Most likely to end up on Saturday night live
Is true. (background applauding)
Yeah.
Okay Heidi we've hit some headlines with us.
Yes, I love to
Yes,
Okay, first step I love this story about Dan Levy.
He recently hosted SNL for the first time in entertainment.
Weekly reports that before he left, Dan wrote a little note
for the next host of Saturday night, live Regina King.
And then she left one, Heidi, take it away.
Tell us what happened.
You're there.
We don't need an entertainment weekly.
You are literally right there,
I'm right there.
Break it down
So then Regina leaves one for reggae, Sean Page,
then Reggae Sean Page leaves one for Nick Jonas.
And it's just like and it's all just little,
good luck have fun.
Just like being sweet to each other.
I love this so much.
It's like when presidents leave,
after their four years or eight years
they leave a little note in the desk for the nest president.
This is so brilliant hosting us or not.
I can't even imagine what that's like.
So if you've never done it
the fact that you could leave a little note
a guidance for the next person is beautiful.
Yes. And it's so Dan levy, he's so sweet.
When he hosted, I was coming
in to like talk to him about something.
And before I left, he was like, do you want a cookie?
And I was like, yes, I want a cookie.
And then we rehearse.
We rehearsed for five more hours that day.
At the end of the night
it's like 11 he's, come get another cookie.
And I was like, you are so nice (laughing)
Wow,
He just fed me the whole week.
I think that we should take a page pun intended
from a Dan Levy's idea and just start doing this.
It's like this, pay it forward yet, Connect back.
It's so wonderful.
Yeah,
The next story comes to us from.
China, and it's working huge conversation
on Chinese social media.
And I want your thoughts.
The New York post reports
a divorce court has ordered a man to pay his wife $7,700
for her housework after five years of marriage.
And it's part
of a new divorce law that says a partner who takes
on the unpaid work, caring for the kids
caring for the elderly or helping
with the partner's job is entitled to compensation.
You have to think about the time, the effort
all that hard work, that the partner that doesn't work
at a traditional job puts in it has to be a value.
And is it monetary?
I mean, I've never heard
of anything like this, Heidi, what do you think?
I think, heck yeah.
You see amount out of Amazon packaging.
My husband leaves around when he opens
up the app and I have a job, and I'm picking that up.
I would like money for that.
Yes
(background laugh)
Everybody grab a banana (all laughing)
because it's time for food news.
(background applauding)
May I ask what's the first thing you want to
do when you grab a banana?
Call my Nana.(all laughing)
Okay. What a writer at refinery 29, went
on a quest to determine the correct way to peel a banana.
And the answer might surprise you, Heidi.
Can you read that? Tell us what it says.
It's from the bottom up.
No, this is
That shocked me.
This is banana.(all laughing)
That's crazy.
Is it from down here.
Apparently we've been doing it all wrong.
Apparently going backwards, going the other way round.
Avoids that mealy tip.
What do you think Heidi?
Well, I also find the bottom to be mealy
and I cut that off too.
So I only eat a banana, in this much.
Have you ever peeled it from the bottom?
I have not
Let's do it.
All right. Here we go.
It feels wrong.
Oh my God.
It's so much better.
And so much more delicate to not crank on the handle.
I didn't like that.
It just felt like against nature (Heidi laughing)
Ross. I'm totally with you.
I say no.
Yeah, no, I'm good.
Okay.
This banana can split, (all laughing) so stupid.
Heidi, would you like to read the next
Or do it?
Yes, I would love to, (applauding)
well, we clearly love a good snack
on this show.
Me included I'm new, but I love it.
So this next story is right down our alley.
The Guardian reports, people have found a new way to penpal
by sharing snacks.
It started on Reddit and basically you can link up
with someone across the globe and swap snacks with them.
So someone in Australia could trade you Vegemite
and some emu jerky for your flaming hot Cheetos.
Sign me up.
Yes.
Are you kidding me?
The only thing I like more than friends is food.
This is perfect.
Anyone in Germany want to send me
A crowd?
Yeah. Whatever one of those too.
Yeah. We'll have three of those.
Thank you. (Heidi mumbles)
No, I'm good. (all laughing) (Ross mumbles)
Isn't this fun.
Think about that.
You can meet people around the world
and try all the different cuisine
and more than just the cuisine, the snacks, right?
Because they're so different.
Heidi, you have a really special pen pal story
and you started doing it in the pandemic.
Will you tell us about it.
Yes. So right when the pandemic started and we were all
at home and didn't know what to do, I was like
what can I do to help right now?
And I was like, I bet senior citizens are really
lonely right now in retirement homes.
So I started writing them letters and cards and
I did it as a way to give back.
But of course, when you give
you receive so much more and then the rest
of the monster in the pandemic, I've been getting letters
from people all across the country.
One of them, her name's Veera in cascade, Iowa.
And there some women in Kansas city who like we write
to each other about Alanis Morissette songs.
I mean, it's been very cool and therapeutic
Everything you just said was so heartfelt
and it just changed my body language
and the feeling I had inside
because it's so positive and good and connective.
And I'm so glad that you did that.
And I would love to jump on the snail mail train with you.
Oh my God. You've got to write to Veera too.
I would love to write to Veera,
That's sweet
I'm in.
Okay.
Next Heidi, you actually brought us a delicious snack.
We don't even have to pen palette.
You brought it right here.
Yes, so this is from my hometown, Kansas city, Missouri.
And if anyone knows me
I love my hometown so much and we are famous for barbecue.
One of my favorites is Arthur Bryant's
and these are their famous, burnt ends.
So excited.
And I do know that you are such a Kansas city Patriot.
(chuckles) I really am
Yeah, you really are. I love that
You're in a diet.
Oh my God.
One of the things that's so amazing.
If a barbecue sauce can really come up
into your like old factories and kind of circle up
into the nostril and be like, almost like a what's Sabi
like experience.
This is unbelievable, Heidi.
Yes. Thank you.
(laughs) You're welcome.
I am just so honored. You would come here.
Heidi is on SNL
obviously Saturdays at 11.30, Eastern, 10.30 central
(confident music)